I'm thrilled to have here for the first
time ever somebody who I've been I've
known for a very long time rooted for
him when he was on the campus at the
University of Michigan and interviewed
him covered him and now pleased to be
able to call a friend a three-time Super
Bowl champion five-time Pro Bowler
two-time leader in interceptions in the
National Football League season good to
see you time long man thank you for
having me rich man this is this is
awesome by the way misses the nicest
said I've ever been on no kid no ABS
you've been on a ton of sets yeah I've
been on a ton assist but this is
comfortable you feel I feel like I'm at
home
good that's the idea formal cross my
ladies and get Kyle here so let's let's
let's hit on the first subject jaylen
Ramsey everyone's talking about a court
I mean a corner giving unvarnished
opinions on quarterbacks throughout the
league what do you think of what Jalen
has done I think it's awesome
I mean he's putting himself out there he
he feels that he's the best cornerback
in in football and I agree with him he's
the best young cornerback in football he
is kind of reminiscent of Deion Sanders
when he first came out he's taking the
league by storm and he's putting his
money where his mouth is but you don't
think that he's drawn more of a target
to the team or that's what you want no I
I know you do but to say somebody sucks
I mean that's it I mean those
quote-unquote sucks you know what now
he's he's a little bit harsh with it you
know I mean I wouldn't take that
approach but that's who Jalen Ram Ramsey
is so if he thinks you suck as a
quarterback the time you play him he's
challenging you to come after him you
know what I mean so if you're gonna
challenge him go at him you know I mean
but if he's if he can back it up talk as
much trash as you want because uh you
know he's gonna be around for a long
time so I guess that's one thing is that
you put a target on your back and you
can walk the walk and talk the talk you
can i that that I get what about what he
said about his own his own house and and
again let's just review what that is
where he talks about how Blake bortles
and is he the play off Blake is somebody
that he likes but but that he wouldn't
that he goes against the scout team in
practice because if he went against them
it might mess with his confidence is
what he said
well I think some of those commas need
to stay in house but I did the same
thing you know going on the scout team
so I can play against the Tom Brady you
know whoever the starting quarterback
was I wanted to get challenged day in
and day out you write practice on the
scout team yes I went from the scout
team just to get the reps out I feel
that I needed you know what I mean I
think any good cornerback will do so you
want to go out there not just against
the scout team while receivers I need to
be playing against Detroit Browns I need
to be playing against the Randy Moss
says Tom Brady's that's who I need to be
playing against in practice to prepare
for the game so I totally get where he's
coming from
hmm but he's he's let stuff in house out
there Tommy also talked about the play
calling and it was correct the play
calling was very conservative in the AFC
championship game last year and it was
predictable run run pass right and that
you know they should have had more
confidence in Blake bortles but I guess
let me ask you this question how do you
think Tom Coughlin is taking all this
today in Jacksonville you know uh well I
think Tom Coughlin is gonna put his foot
down he's probably gonna pull Jalen into
his office say look you know what
happens here in Jacksonville in this
locker room it stays within the locker
room if you have a problem with somebody
on your team you talk about it here not
through the social media not through the
media and things like that so I think
he's gonna take a little bit of time to
get through to him but he's gonna put
the hammer down cuz everyone knows how
much of a disciplinarian Tom coughing is
and he'll change that program around
how would Belichick have handled us if
you'd if you had told this to GQ Manning
Manning isn't all that I would have been
I was keep going on Belichick is gonna
bring it in right away he's gonna
probably give you all tomato you know I
mean if it depends on what type of
player you are who you are as far as
part of organization if you someone like
Jay Lorenz he's not gonna get cut you're
not gonna threaten him like that because
he'll get picked up in a hot second
everyone knows that but he's gonna let
them know that this is how we do things
around here
and either you get on board or I'm gonna
find a way to get you out of here but
also you wouldn't have tried it right
and I'm not me I'm not saying that
that because of this your own personal
choice that's Bella check there right
see what I'm saying is that and I love
Jalen Ramsey all right and I I me too
man
I'd love just the way he plays and I do
love like I said at the top of the show
nobody talks about how don't the Jaguars
gonna have a target on their back
nobody's ever said those words ever in
20-some odd years okay no matter how how
successful they have been prior to last
year as well getting an ANSI championing
under the complan regime but the the
issue is it that Ramsey knowing that's
Tom Coughlin upstairs and that's Doug
Marrone they're still talk to the GQ
reporting he has to know that this
stuff's gonna come out like you would
have tried it with Belichick respect
what I have to admit as a young player
you know I've probably did a few things
or said a few things that didn't go
across well but you gotta understand
he's still a young guy he's a Pro Bowl
he's already one of the you know top
dogs in the league and he's still
learning how to be the ultimate
professional so I think they're gonna
embrace his brashness his confidence
right now as far as organization yeah
normally the quarterback is the face of
the organization but he's slowly but
surely becoming the Jacksonville Jaguar
talks about when you talk about that
team right now you're talking about
Jalen Ramsey and it might be a method to
his madness he wants to bring the
attention to himself because he knows he
can back it up you know because people
are gonna root for him to lose you know
a lot of people don't like you know when
an athlete comes out and and is that
confident that brash and able to talk
you know about their teammates or
whoever else across the league is just
certain things that you typically you
typically don't do or don't hear from a
player but you know he's like bring it
so I mean I love it and I think that the
team is gonna embrace it but Tom
Coughlin is probably gonna be like you
know what let's tone it down a little
bit I want you to be who you are as long
as you're out there playing good
football helping us win back in 60
seconds with Ty law we'll head on the
Patriots I'd love to know what you think
of what's going through the minds of
Earl Thomas and Richard Sherman who are
obviously in two different spots right
now one who's holding out in in the in
the place that he's only known
professionally in Seattle and another
guy
who's coming off an Achilles injury and
trying to be a top-notch corner in in
his 30s
coming up ty law here and back at 60
seconds on the show the pride of
Aliquippa PA ty long here in the Rich
Eisen show how do you go from
Pennsylvania to the University of
Michigan how'd you get to Michigan from
there you know what the plan to be
honest with you was to go and play in
the ACC you know that was my dream
coming out of high school but at the end
of the day what was most important to me
was for my grandfather to see me play it
was a little far to get to where I
wanted to go for him to see me so I
decided to go to the University of
Michigan you know at the last minute I
think I was a last recruit signed at the
time and and it worked out for the best
that was the best decision that I ever
made but I based it totally on my
grandfather being able to see me playing
but if he couldn't come we're playing
five or six games on national TV
sure oh it's out so he wasn't living in
no it was uh Pennsylvania I was raised
by my grandparents yeah Oh interesting
yeah he never missed the game before but
I definitely wanted to leave
Pennsylvania I didn't want to go to
Peter Penn State I want to make a name
for myself coming up he's the next Tony
Dorsett isn't it no I wanted to be the
first title also I want to do my own
thing and when you were there you you
were the guy who was helping recruit
Charles what's yep yep I was the one
assigned to Charles Woodson and they
have to give him to take him on his
recruiting trip had to be the one you
know checking up on him and giving him
the phone calls and things like that
trying to get in the University of
Michigan so from Ohio from Ohio you know
and and and I was very glad to do that
you know I mean I wasn't a Buckeye fan
still not a Buckeye fan respect him but
I'm a Wolverine all the way so I'm glad
that I was able to steal one of their
best help still one of their best to
bring him in universe Michigan and he
gets the Heisman Trophy goes on to a you
know being a great player that he was in
college and the pros in the future
hall-of-famer so it's awesome and then
it's amazing how on one snowy night in
New England mm-hmm in the backfield
of a playoff game between the Raiders
and patients converging in the backfield
is Charles Woodson and Tom Brady and
ball comes loose Tuck rule appropriately
plot a very appropriate very approach
I talked with Charles Woodson about this
comes he'll this day Charles does not
want to talk about that if I bring it up
his in Jogja he he gets a little
irritated so of course I just got a no
dig a little bit more because it was
funny because after the game you know
normally every time I play against
Charles we meet up in the parking lot
and you know just chop it up but after
that game I'm coming you know by his
busses I'm like work well Charles you
know what I mean gonna come all this boy
so I seen when he came up I was like
would he walk straight on the bus so in
typical tile off fashion I'm gonna go
and save me you gonna come talk to me
imagine it's just a game even though to
go to the Super Bowl so I walked on on
the bus on the front of the bus
not like would you know all your graders
I boarded the Raiders bus and then
everybody was sitting there looking as I
said even come on he said man I ain't
with that man ain't with that and I was
like that's why y'all lost anyway now
ran the whole team bout get up was like
you know bother try to come chasing me
and still like that so I hurry but ran
off the bus yeah you're quick first step
came oh yeah oh yeah that first step
came in handy but Charles was pissed but
I say you know what we go beyond this
game and I understand that you was upset
that we're going to the Superbowl but I
had to give it to him and I say that's
why it's gonna be a long-ass flight home
and I ran so so he didn't he never
forgave me for that too so that's why
you know I got to keep my head on the
swivel if I ever go to Oakland what's
your what's your relationship with Brady
like now Todd relationship with Brady is
great I just seen him up at training
camp you know about a week ago you know
we got to chop it up a little bit and uh
you know we go back I was I sold Brady
his first home he bought my home when he
wasn't making any money and I signed a
new contract so I so Brady my house I
left all the furniture the TV's the pool
tables know that cuz he was you know he
was a you know Miskin guy you had to
take him up under the wing and he was a
you know relative you know nobody at the
time he was just you know barely on the
team and so I had to take care of me no
actually
left about a hundred twenty thirty grand
on the table said you get a hometown
yeah gave hometown discount but I could
say he was moving already all he had to
do is bring his bags in so he remembers
that and appreciates that but now you
know Tom Brady
he has blossomed to who he is right now
and I could probably fit in my whole
house in his kitchen man you know in
heat this week on his weekly radio
appearance up in Boston I mean it was
all rose petals about talking about
Belichick in a way I mean he was just
pleading the fifth you know a couple of
months ago what what is the real
relationship between him and bill well I
think it is they have a good
relationship you know and now and I
think they respect one another they want
a lot of championships a lot a lot of
football games they're gonna go down as
the greatest quarterback coach combo in
the history of teams NFL or team sports
period so you know my question to people
when they talk about the relationship if
you've been in any type of relationship
whether it's your job whether it's a
marriage for eighteen years you're bound
to have some disagreements you're about
to have some issues with your boss
something you know what I mean so I
think because of the the platform and
who they are in this world today with
social media now everything gets blown
out of proportion but you're not gonna
always get along I didn't always get
along with every coach even though I
love and respect them we're trying to
accomplish the same things as far as
championships and winning football games
and that's the same thing with coach
Belichick and Tom Brady they're gonna
keep it in-house
you know a couple things got out and I
think more speculation than anything and
they created this story but you have
never seen those two guys buy into it
because when you see them talking it's
about love respect and winning football
games are they out there having dinner
every other week probably not but at the
end of the day when it's all said and
done they know who they are and they
know what their relationship is about
and the trainer that's no there's that's
nothing to see here
the fact that he he told Alex Carrera to
go across the street Alison grill was
already across the street I mean he
couldn't come into the facility period
well that's not true either because I
like us
I was just that training camp in Alice
Guerrero was right there still working
with Tom at the facility he wasn't hit
and so I don't understand with this
whole hoopla is all about because after
practice and the one thing that I must
note about Tom Brady as well
they had just got done with practice
where does he do he goes in trains again
with Alex Guerrero they out there doing
his throwing motions and things like
that in the stadium so he's done
practicing why everyone showering Tom
Brady is still trying is still so great
that he's going above and beyond he's
one of the oldest in the league
definitely the oldest in that locker
room and he's the one out there still
practicing why everybody's taking the
shower with Alex Guerrero he said he
wants to play till 2020 at least I
believe him and he can't as long as you
protect him you know he's gonna go out
there and play as long as as long as he
feel he can be effective why right I
mean he's got no I just he's got it
that's who he is he's always feeling
like he has something to prove even
though we all know there is nothing else
to prove there is no argument about who
the goat is when it comes to the
quarterback position anymore I don't
want to hear arguably take that word out
of it when you talk to Tom Brady he is
definitely the greatest quarterback
who's ever you know lace them up and
that's without a doubt so he's still
with him his within himself feels like
he has something to prove and that's
what makes him great Tyler here on the
Rich Eisen show what do you think's
going through Earl Thomas is mine right
now ty probably a sense of loneliness
right now because you know most of his
compadres that he's played with and
created a legion of boom with argon so
he's there in an unfamiliar situation
even though he's been with the Seattle
Seahawks his whole career he's like
looking around my boys are gone I've
been there before myself and he's seeing
all these players getting big paydays
and he's been established and he knows
his window was closing as far as getting
another opportunity for a big payday so
he's looking at all those things so you
know he's just trying to leverage you
know who he is to the organization with
the type of player he is right now
before he gets another year or so older
to get one more last payday
in rifle e so how difficult steep a
challenge do you think it is for Richard
Sherman coming back from an Achilles how
do you think his I mean I think
physically everyone handles injuries
different how you bounce back but I
think Richard one he's a very very smart
intelligent person before a football
player he's a good football player as
well and you know great cornerback so
it's gonna be interesting to see how he
bounces back but I think if he's not
there physically just yet he knows
enough mentally to play the game because
I remember as a player with New York I
wasn't physically the same player you
know I was coming off of a foot injury I
was probably 10 12 pounds heavier than I
have a play with so I couldn't play
physically like I wanted to but I was
sharp enough mentally and I had enough
experience mentally to still excel and I
ended up leading the league in
interceptions with 10 you know what I
mean and that was playing from from a
mental standpoint just playing games
with the quarterback playing the guest
receivers and playing mind games but
physically I couldn't go out there and
do the same things that I used to do so
hopefully Richards game evolved to that
if he's not physically able to do what
he used to do do you think of the Hall
of Fame often when people ask me about
it but I don't lose any sleep over it
because I understand the process I know
it's hard
I'm very blessed to even be in the
conversation you know when I was a
finalist the last couple years and just
to be in the room with all those gold
jackets and all that greatness seeing
the guys I looked up to like the Mean
Joe green Tony Dorsett some the guys
that I played with and just the fact
that I'm being mentioned and I'm here as
one of the 15 guys that has an
opportunity that's a blessing in itself
you know I mean so you know if it's
meant to happen it will of course do you
want it to happen absolutely do you feel
that but everyone in that room all 15
guys have a story and have a case
so I'm realistic about that you know
what I mean but I said let's let the
chips fall where they may but hopefully
one day I'll get to be a part of a new
team so if you are you you'll go right
oh absolutely
absolutely and I really think you know I
respect and love to yo so much I mean as
a colleague as a person that dad we
played in the same era everyone knows
that tio should have been a first-ballot
hall-of-famer I'm sitting there in the
room with him wanting to be chosen
myself but if I had a vote I'm picking
tio because he's supposed to be there
you know and everyone knows that I just
think that he could have handled it a
little bit differently but that's tio
you can't tell him you know what he's
gonna do you know I mean but I look at
it is you had the biggest platform that
you can possibly have if you wanted to
make a statement you have 30 minutes at
the Hall of Fame ceremony to say
whatever you had to say you want to cuss
somebody out you can cuss him out right
here and tell everybody how you feel
about it but more importantly missing
the opportunity to bond with your new
teammates show them the love and respect
they deserve by paving the way and
welcoming you to the family that's the
thing that he's never gonna get back but
you know I respect what he's what he did
and chosen are doing his own way and I'm
just gonna leave that debt I think he's
a great player he's a Hall of Famer no
one's gonna ask how many years it took
you to get your yellow jacket you got
that gold jacket now yeah and you know
ty I appreciate you coming on I hope you
you get that jacket you deserve I
appreciate it I did you know you deserve
it immensely and plus I would love for
you to get that jacket so you can go
into the Hall of Fame and see the guy in
a gold jacket who changed the rules of
football because you picked his
quarterback off three times in the 2004
AFC champion because that's what Bill
Polian did right huh yeah he he gave me
a hard time but as I look at as a sign
of respect even though it's probably not
written like that when whatever rule
book but but it's the time it's the tile
out rule I mean I like that I mean it
sounds good to me
well I don't know if you want that
because of all these little acts all
these flags that we see of illegal
contact kneeled on third down
the world when it's the plays not even
run there I'm glad I know what I'm glad
I ain't playing right now because with
all the fans going on in the way I was
taught to play the game I probably
wouldn't get no check you know at the
end of the week because I take your
money too much but it was originally two
male blunt room so I'm talking to a male
and I was like he is one of the greatest
to ever do it so now two years later to
say it's the tie law rule I mean I'm
sitting there with male blood man I feel
good like Mel Blount rule by the Thai
law re-emphasis yes absolutely
good to see you Terry Thank You Man
official Thai law on Twitter and then
what's your business the folks should
get up to do launch trampoline park and
my sneaker closet calm you know those
are my two business entities so check it
out check us out on Instagram Twitter
man we did we do anything well that's
great it's good to see you anytime you
got Thai law here in the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience